Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Vous souvenez-vous de la consigne de lait
de nos parents, de nos grands-parents ?
À peu près.
C'est plutôt simple.
Il y avait un contenant en verre
qu’on achetait chez l’épicier,
qui était automatiquement
ramené à la source.
Comment on faisait ?
On mettait une consigne monétaire
de quelques centimes dès l’achat
qui garantissait le retour.
Le réemploi était plutôt monnaie
courante à cette époque.
Quand il n’y avait pas de consigne, on
venait avec ses bocaux, boîte à œufs, etc.
Pourtant, fin des années...
Fin des années...
(Applaudissements)
Fin des années 90 exactement,
la multiplication des produits a rendu
impossible le maintien de la consigne.
C’est le règne du plastique
jetable à faible coût.
Bienvenue dans les 30 glorieuses
où jeter a un goût de modernité.
Ce que je vais expliquer
est plutôt simple.
Je ne suis pas chercheuse,
mais une citoyenne qui a pris conscience
de certaines choses il y a quelques années
et j’ai décidé d’agir.
Je vous parle de déchets, en fait.
Vous vous doutez bien que ce soir,
il n’y a pas d’emballage jetable.
Ce soir, quand vous allez manger, vous
allez éviter 1500 emballages jetables.
[On évite] ces 1500 emballages jetables
parce qu’il y a des contenants
réutilisables qu’on a mis sur place.
Ces contenants réutilisables, uniquement
les 1500, éviteront à eux seuls
2 160 000 emballages jetables
dans leur vie.
Imaginez.
Ils vont être lavés et continueront
à raconter une belle histoire.
En fait, c’est simple.
Il y a des analyses de cycle de vie
qui montrent que dès la 22e réutilisation,
un contenant en verre réutilisable
a un meilleur bilan
que son simulacre
en emballage jetable carton.
Quand on sait qu’un verre trempé,
par exemple,
a une durée de vie
de 2000 cycles de lavage,
on peut arriver
à une belle mesure d’impact.
Mon message ce soir est très simple.
Il est déjà en place sur certaines villes,
notamment Clermont-Ferrand.
Mutualisons les contenants en verre
au sein de nos villes.
Tirons les leçons du passé
et proposons un nouveau modèle,
un modèle où en fait,
il y a des partenaires -
restaurateurs, artisans de métiers
de bouche, ou dans l’événementiel,
qui agissent dans ce sens.
Un réseau où les mangeurs - vous et moi -
ne sont plus obligés
de rapporter ces contenants
dans un seul restaurant, mais dans
n’importe quel restaurant du réseau.
Un réseau où on accompagne
les restaurateurs
parce que, en 2023,
il y a une loi qui va passer
et le réemploi deviendra obligatoire
pour certains établissements.
Mais vous vous doutez bien qu’eux
ne sont pas du tout dotés de plonge,
de service logistique, etc.
C’est pour ça que
de tels réseaux se créent.
Il n’est pas unique en France,
heureusement ;
il n’y en a pas beaucoup,
mais de plus en plus.
C’est un réseau qui agit localement,
résilient,
mais qui aussi se nourrit
et alimente les autres réseaux de France.
Et j’espère,
que vous soyez Clermontois ou pas,
que, ce soir,
vous allez comprendre ce message.
(Applaudissements)